this Israeli checkpoint near nablas in
the occupied West bank is closed at
least for now Palestinian drivers
waiting to move in and out of the city
are at a
standstill no one knows when or if
they'll be allowed to continue their
Journey traffic is moving at another
checkpoint near nais but 74-year-old
Muhammad Khal says it's taking too long
last week I spent three hours at this
checkpoint so by the time I arrived to
my destination to drop off the shipment
it was too late and the stores were
closed long before the war on Gaza
started Palestinians suffered from
Israeli military checkpoints that
isolate and disconnect cities and towns
from one another as the Israeli assault
in Gaza increases so does the number of
Israeli obstacles in the occupied West
Bank new Gates have been installed
Israeli soldiers hold the keys with no
restriction on Israeli Cars Moving in
the occupied territory rights
organization say before the war there
were around 77 activated and man
checkpoints after the war more than 500
checkpoints were reactivated and around
140 new ones established in total we're
talking about more than 700 checkpoints
cement blocks dirt mounds and Gates many
are totally shut like the one behind me
Omar bini is a go-to taxi driver for
Road knowledge in the occupied West Bank
after 37 years in the business he knows
the shortcuts and how to avoid closures
but many of the alternative routes are
undeveloped we joined Omar for a drive
from ramala to ginine a journey that
shouldn't take more than 2 hours
roadblocks closed roads and three
checkpoints later we reached our
destination a journey which took us
twice as long more than four hours not
to stress anxiety humiliation extra cost
and waste of time they want to make our
lives hard and complicated so we
eventually
leave the alternative routes mean being
stuck being blocked being
frustrated it resembles much of the
Palestinian story a life spent in
Waiting n ibraim Al jaaz the occupied
West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer